>> JULIAN HAS OWNED HAS BEEN
HELD IN A HIGH-SECURITY A HIGH
SECURITY PRISON SOMETHING WAS
LAST SPRING IN LONDON WHERE HE
WAS HELD FOR MANY YEARS IN
ISOLATION.
HIS EXTRADITION HEARING IS
FINALLY UNDERWAY.
HIS LAWYER ESTIMATES HE COULD
FACE 175 YEARS IN PRISON IF HE’S
EXTRADITED TO THE UNITED STATES
AND HE FACES AS ME NOT CHARGES
HAVE GREAT WIKILEAKS EXPOSED ALL
KINDS OF THINGS SOME OF IT WAS
GOOD TO KNOW.
SO WHAT IS THE STORY ON HIM AND
WHY IS THE DOJ PURSUING THIS
CASE SO AGGRESSIVELY.
HE IS A JOURNALIST AND WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE HIM HERE TONIGHT.
GLENN, THANK YOU FOR COMING ON.
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE HEARD
FROM YEARS THAT HE IS A BAD GUY
HE HEARD THE UNITED STATES AND
NOW THE UNITED STATES IS GOING
TO BRING JUSTICE IN THIS CASE.
TELL US WHAT WE SHOULD KNOW IN
THREE MINUTES ABOUT HIM KICKING
LET’S REMEMBER, TUCKER THAT THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO AND
BEGAN BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE IN 2010
THEY PUBLISHED A SLEW OF
DOCUMENTS, NONE OF THEM HARMED
ANYBODY, NOT EVEN THE GOVERNMENT
IT WAS VERY EMBARRASSING TO THE
OBAMA MINISTRATION IT REVEALED
ALL THE LIES THEY WERE TELLING
ABOUT THESE ENDLESS WARS THAT
THE PENTAGON AND THE CIA WERE
DETERMINED TO FIGHT.
THEY WERE EMBARRASSING SO THEY
INITIATED A JEEP GRAND JURY
INVESTIGATION TO TRY TO
PROSECUTE HIM FOR REPORTING TO
THE PUBLIC.
HE WORKED WITH THE NEW YORK
TIMES, THE GUARDIAN TO PUBLISH
VERY EMBARRASSING INFORMATION
ABOUT THE ENDLESS WAR MACHINE,
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT’S HAPPENING
HERE WE CAN LOOK AT A SIMILAR
CASE WHICH IS ONE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP RECENTLY RAISED WHICH IS
THE PROSECUTION BY THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AND WHERE
IT SNOWED IN FOR THE SAME REASON
THAT HE EXPOSED THE LIES THAT
JAMES CLAPPER TOLD, HE EXPOSED
HOW FAIR IS THIS MASSIVE SPYING
SYSTEM AT THE NSA AND THE CA
CONTROL THAT THEY CAN USE
AGAINST AMERICAN CITIZENS.
THIS ISN’T COMING FROM PRESIDENT
TRUMP COMING HE PRAISED
WIKILEAKS FOR INFORMING THE
PUBLIC PRAYER HE KNOWS FIRSTHAND
HOW THESE SPYING SYSTEMS THE
EDWARD SNOWDEN COULD BE ABUSED
AND REUSED IN 2016 PAIRED THESE
ARE COMING FROM PEOPLE WORKING
IN THE CIA AND PENTAGON WHO
INSIST ON ENDLESS WAR AND
BELIEVE THEY ARE A GOVERNMENT
UNTO THEMSELVES.
MORE POWERFUL THAN THE PRESIDENT
.
I POST THIS WEEKEND AS SPEECH
FROM DWIGHT EISENHOWER WHAT WE
NOW CALL THE DEEP STATE IS
BECOMING MORE POWERFUL THAN THE
PRESIDENT CHUCK SCHUMER WARMED
RIGHT BEFORE PRESIDENT TRUMP
CHALLENGING THE CIA WAS FOOLISH
BECAUSE THEY HAVE MANY WAYS TO
GET BACK AT ANYBODY WHO IMPEDES
THEM THAT’S WHAT THESE CASES ARE
ABOUT.
THEY ARE PUNISHING JULIAN
ASSANGE AND SNOWED IN FOR
INFORMING THE PUBLIC ABOUT
THINGS THEY DESERVE TO KNOW
ABOUT THE OBAMA MINISTRATION
PAIR THEY’RE SAYING TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP, YOU DON’T RUN THE COUNTRY
, WE DO IN THEIR DARING
HIM TO USE HIS PARKING POWER TO
PUT AN END TO THESE VERY ABUSIVE
PROSECUTIONS, ONE WHICH RESULTED
IN EIGHT YEARS OF PUNISHMENT FOR
JULIAN ASSANGE AND ONE THAT WAS
SEVEN YEARS OF EXILE EDWARD
SNOWDEN FOR INFORMING THE PUBLIC
AND EMBARRASSING POLITICAL
OFFICIALS WHO ARE VERY RIGHT.
>> IN 30 SECONDS, THE PRESIDENT.
>> HE COULDN’T FIRED HIM BETWEEN
THE RIGHT AND THE LEFT FOR BEING
TO BOTH.
IT WOULD BE POLITICALLY
ADVANTAGEOUS FOR THE PRESIDENT
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO WOULD BE
ANGRY WOULD BE THE ONES WHO BOTH
OF THEM EXPOSED.